face of saudi arabia
as minister of foreign affairs it's he
who presents the country's foreign
policy
and he's about to take his case against
iran to this week's u.n general assembly
in new york
is saudi arabia prepared for war
we hope by any means to avoid war nobody
wants
war war is destructive we have
priorities that involve reforming our
country
we have a responsibility to defend our
country
and to ensure that no harm comes to our
country or our people or our residents
and so we will do whatever it takes to
prevent
our country from sustaining damages
preparing for war war is always the last
option
sky news has been shown the damage to
the two saudi oil facilities after last
weekend's drone and missile attacks
the saudi and u.s governments have said
evidence will soon implicate iran beyond
doubt
so you're absolutely convinced that
these
drones and missiles came from iranian
soil
we don't know that yet there's suspicion
because they came from the north but
what we do know is that the missiles and
the drones are iranian
on wednesday the saudi ministry of
defense produced what it said was
wreckage from eight of the kamikaze
drones
and two misfired cruise missiles all
iranian-made
there are skeptics out there quite a lot
of people simply don't believe that this
was the work of iran and they take the
houthi view
that this was self-defense for for your
operations in yemen
our military explained a few days ago
that
impossible for these missiles to be to
come from yemen because they don't have
the range
much has been made in the past week
about america's commitment to its old
ally
saudi arabia donald trump has promised
his supporters fewer wars not more
he has now authorized the deployment of
u.s military to the region
but only as a defensive measure are you
absolutely convinced
that donald trump has your back
donald trump has been a very strong
president and a very strong advocate of
the u.s saudi relationship
donald trump has been very firm in
dealing with iran he's committed to
enhancing
our military cooperation our security
cooperation so we have no doubt in
donald trump but he's also committed to
having fewer wars not more wars so are
you not a bit worried that matt perhaps
he'll
want you to fight this one alone if it
comes to it everybody
wants to avoid wars everybody everybody
what about the uk have you asked for a
british for british help militarily
the uk also has been one of our
staunchest allies when it comes to
security and we are consultations with
the united kingdom on this area
the united kingdom has agreed to provide
naval
assets in order to help with maritime
security
in tehran for yet another day iran has
said that any strike on its country
would be met with
overwhelming force and so a week on
from an attack that hit saudi arabia the
global oil market and
regional security it is still not clear
where this goes next
the un meeting this coming week comes at
a perfect moment